today during this tutorial we'll be
learning how to build an app to find
similar images using deep learning um
but before we get started uh we want to
make sure that everybody is installed
with graphlab create so how can I get a
show of hands how many folks have
managed to
install Okay um and how many folks have
managed to get the the data necessary
either from this landing page right here
or from the USB sticks in the
back okay so lots of folks don't have
the data yet um so you can either follow
this
link and go to scroll
down uh to download the tutorial content
and click on this link here oh hold on
it's not uh
showing one
moment I had a a different screen than
you guys okay so if you follow that
link and
you there we
[Music]
go and you scroll down to download the
tutorial
content and you click on that link you
can download it it's quite a lot so if
the Wi-Fi is being slow you can also ask
for a USB stick uh there we have some
Tas around the room uh and especially in
the back there so grab a USB stick
download the uh the data and unzip it uh
one important note is just to make sure
your installation is working uh go ahead
and open up IPython and import graph lab
construct an S frame and uh just execute
this last line of code as well and if
you have any
problems uh go ahead and grab rtas raise
your hand and they'll come to you so any
questions
just USB stick just a USB stick okay
great so let's get started uh with the
presentation with the Talk
part all
right one
moment
view exit full
screen okay
so as Al Alice mentioned uh I'm an
employee at dat dat is a company of
about 40 people I guess at this point
and we're located in Fremont and
we're uh
developing a platform to help Implement
manage and optimize the production ml
pipeline uh it looks like this this
slide got a little distorted on the
screen there but uh the pipeline
basically consists of data ingestion
engineering um some machine learning so
generating models on that data and then
deploying those models so that they can
be consumed by folks in the outside
world so today we'll be focusing on the
Deep learning portion of that pipeline
we'll be applying deep learning to that
Pipeline and so deep learning has
been basically everywhere in the news
recently um also it's been used by many
major companies in production already so
Facebook is using it for face detection
um I believe many of the big companies
Google BYU and Facebook are using it in
general for just object
classification it's also been uh made
major research news um for instance a
little while ago Google Deep Mind built
a system which plays video games using
deep learning and so but all of
these have one thing in common and that
is that uh they're very complex systems
and they're difficult to understand and
um not very approachable by just general
people so the goal of the talk today is
to hit the easy button on deep
learning um and we'll be doing that
basically by first just going over uh
deep learning
fundamentals and getting a fundamental
understanding of what's going on so you
get a little bit of an intuition and
then we're going to uh open up our I
python notebooks and get our hands dirty
first we'll train a fairly simple model
on the emus data set which which is the
character recognition data set and then
uh we're going to do something really
cool we're going to using deep learning
build a similar dress
recommender um just to give you guys
psyched I'm going to uh demonstrate how
it's going to
work all right so we're out of
presentation mode and we're in Google
Chrome okay now let's go back
to full
screen okay so this is a a simple front
end wrapper on what we're building today
it was made by a few Folks at
datto and I'm going to type a keyword
dress and I have a bunch of dresses that
come up okay let's make it a little bit
bigger can you everybody see
it yes are we good okay
awesome um and the way this works is you
select one of these
dresses and it goes into a data set of
uh dress images and it finds the most
similar one uh and it does so
exclusively based on visual features
there's no uh text metadata that's being
used and it's all powered by Deep
learning so hopefully by the end of this
tutorial today uh all of you will have a
good understanding of how this works
all right let's go back to the
presentation
um exit full screen I wish I knew better
shortcuts all right are we back
up okay so really deep learning is all
about features so let's put this a
little bit in context and uh understand
why features are so key to machine
learning let's start with just like a
really simple machine learning task
which is Spam
filtering
and what happen the goal of the machine
learning task of spam filtering is when
a user opens an email well he or she
thinks it's
spam so the input to this machine
learning model might be just like the
text of an email it might be information
about the user so uh what
what the user has thought was spam in
the past or it might be uh information
about the source so whether or not the
source has been flagged as spam in the
past by other
users um then you put it into some model
and the model tries to learn whether uh
it's spam or not it turns out that this
um can be a hard problem because the
input is quite unstructured so the text
can be of arbitrary length and many
models require fixed length input um
there might be noisy data like uh in the
text body there might be words like ath
and which aren't very indicative of
whether uh the input is Spam or not and
um so usually there's a little bit of
pre-processing that has to go into the
data before it gets consumed by the
model and this is often called
feature
extraction or feature
engineering and feature engineering is
one of those like black art things uh in
machine learning and it's just
transformation of the input data into
something that the model can can
actually purse and so that can be as
simple as just pulling out important
words in this example or it can be a
like a very complex transformation of
the input into some new form
uh so quite a lot of machine learning
research in the past years has been
exactly on how to best perform this
feature
extraction but what makes deep learning
so amazing is that it's uh all about
learning those features without having
to know much about them so to really
understand why learning features is so
cool and so important let's take a step
back and uh look at linear classic
ifers uh linear classifiers are the most
common type of classifier so if you've
ever played with svms or logistic
regression those are linear classifiers
and what they do is they take some space
uh which is filled with positive and
negative examples and they try to draw a
line between the positive and negative
examples such that all positive examples
are one on one side of the line and all
negative examples are on the other
and so in uh multiple Dimensions this
line is called a hyperplane and this
line or hyper plane is parameterized by
what we see here as uh W1 and
W2 and uh
so
anytime W1 * X1 + W2 * X2 plus some
biased term equals z um that's the ision
boundary if it's ever greater than zero
it's positive examples and if it's ever
less than zero it's negative
examples okay so that's cool um it seems
quite simple but still uh a linear
classifier can represent quite a lot of
things it can solve quite a lot of
problems um one example all of you folks
are probably familiar with is the
logical and so this is like uh this is a
graphical representation of a logical
and
on the y- AIS we have the potential
variables or the potential values sorry
of um one
variable and on the xaxis we have the
potential values of the other variable
and if they're both one then uh the and
it's a positive example so one logical
and one is true otherwise it's false and
so we display this graphic
and we can draw a line between the
negative examples and the positive
examples so that's
cool uh if you have an or you can do the
same thing in this case it's only
negative or false if both inputs are
zero but what happens when you have
something like this this is the exor
function uh so the exor function is only
true when only only one of the input
values is
true and so we can't represent this with
a linear classifier we can't learn this
with a linear classifier so we either
need a nonlinear
classifier or we need nonlinear features
so we need to embed this data in the new
space where you can use a linear
classifier and that might look a little
like
this so it's just a transformation of
the input and with this new transformed
input you can draw a line between
positive and negative
examples okay so how do we go about
solving this problem this feature
extraction
problem let's start with looking at a
graph representation of the classifier
the linear classifier we were just
looking at you'll we'll find that it's
pretty useful for defining neural
networks and uh for our understanding of
of how feature extraction can work um so
on the left we have our input Vector uh
X1 through
XD you can see that the one and the two
and the D got cut off a little bit but
that's what they are and the output is
the
Y okay so remember that a linear
classifier is basically a weighted sum
of the input units here um so W1 * X1
plus W2 * X2
Etc so let's represent that graphically
so we have W1 * X1 W2 * X2 Etc and then
you threshold it so that if the output
is greater than zero it's a true or a
positive example if it's less than zero
it's a negative example
okay there's also a bias
term so let's use this
uh sort of representation to go back and
revisit our logical uh our Boolean
operators okay so what weights would we
need to put on these edges to get uh an
X1 or X2 does anybody
know okay um basically if you put in
weights of on on the edges connecting X1
and X2 to Y and uh
0.5 connecting to the bias term you get
the or function and so it works a little
like this
uh if you always have this value of 1 uh
time .5 going into the Y and if either
X1 or X2 are positive or both they um it
brings up the value above zero and so
the the result is true if
however neither X1 nor X2 are true then
those values get set to zero and so the
only input that coming into the uh Y is
1 * .5 so it's less than zero and the uh
the result is false so let's repeat this
exercise for
and uh any ideas for this
one oh
okay so it's going to be 1 1 and 1.5 in
this case only if both X1 and X2 have
values of one will uh the Y output value
be greater than zero or true so that
sort of matches our expectations for how
Boolean operators
work so let's go back to this idea of
feature extraction and uh solving the
exor problem
um so we can rewrite xor with X1 and not
X2 or not X1 and X2 okay so this is just
Boolean algebra and this is breaking it
our problem down into portions which we
already know how to
solve so that's let call that Z1 we
already know how to solve
that that's Z2 we already know how to
solve that and this is our familiar uh
input on the left and output on the
right
okay so let's uh put in
Z1 this is very similar to what we were
just looking at so the only
difference is that this X2 connection
weight is NE -1 because of the
knot okay let's do a Z2 now we threshold
those and we can just or the resulting Z
values and
get our answer so that is uh X1 xor X2
and do this look familiar to anybody
this sort of
representation well this is exactly what
a a neural network looks like the only
difference
is
we
handpicked our values that connect um
units because it was a relatively
straightforward problem but neural
networks given an input and a Target
output learn those parameters okay
so uh this is they're really cool um it
turn turns out that neural Nets that
with enough hidden units they can model
any arbitrary function so that's why
you've been seeing so many amazing
results uh out of research that has to
do with deep
learning but it also comes at a cost so
neuron Nets are really difficult to
train uh as the number of hidden units
grow those numbers of connections grow
as well and so that many parameters
takes too much memory and too much
computation time to
train okay so we have gpus to the rescue
um neural
Nets many operation in the neural net
training can be parallelized basically
neural net training essentially reduces
to Matrix multiplications and that can
be easily parallelized on a
GPU uh nevertheless it's still
computationally intensive so many of
the really performant networks out there
have maybe 20 layers amazing amounts of
layers maybe tens of millions of
parameters and so even with gpus it can
take on the order of months to train so
this idea of convolutional Neal Nets
came along and uh there's a few
different approaches to understanding
convolutional Nets but one of them is
that it's a strategic removal of edges
so let's take a standard fully connected
layer which is very similar to what we
saw before where all the units in the
input layer are connected to all the
units in the hidden layer
okay um and
so turns out that if in many cases a lot
of those uh parameters are learned to be
zero so you can remove them and so now
we have just locally connected units
that's nice we've reduced the number of
parameters we need but we can go even
further we can tie weight values so in
this case all the red edges share a
weight all the blue edges share a weight
and all the green edges share weight and
you can interpret
that as
basically a filter moving along the
input and filling
out the hidden
layer and this is I have a little JF
here of what it might look like in two
dimensions on an actual
image okay so it's moving along and
filling out the the hidden
layer um you can sort of see these
kernels as detectors so maybe they're
moving around the input and they're
trying to detect an edge or maybe
they're trying to detect a cat face or
something but that that's an easy way of
of thinking about what's going
on okay so another type of layer which
is quite common in neural Nets is a
pooling layer and so what a pooling
layer does is it takes a neighborhood
and it reduces it to one value um
so what this does is it allows you to
gain a certain amount of robustness to
the spatial location of features so for
instance uh if you're looking for a face
in a image it doesn't it might not
really matter where the face
is um so you want
the response of the layer to be
identical even with small shifts of the
input um so another side effect of this
pulling is that if you alternate
convolution and pooling um you sort of
the pooling zooms out uh each time you
perform a pulling and the next
convolutional layer is working on a
different scale so at the beginning it
might be working on a very small scale
it might filters might be looking for
things like edges and then later on uh
they might be looking for things like
faces so much larger spatially so I have
another GIF here of what this pooling
might look like um as you can see it
takes a neighborhood and reduces it to
one value
okay so you aggregate all these kinds of
layers into one network
and you get one very complicated thing
this is the uh Alex net some of you may
be familiar with it this is the network
that won the imag net challenge a few
years ago and the key thing to notice
here is is just like we were talking
about uh first there's convolution then
there's pooling then there's convolution
then there's pooling so there's that
alternating scheme and then at the end
you have some fully connected layers
just to um sort of fully integrate the
information that was learned during the
convolution okay so let's move
on any
questions no okay so let's move on
the biggest area that deep learning has
made a contribution to uh and the most
mature sort of deep learning field is
computer vision and so let's dive into
that a little bit
deeper so an example of a computer
vision task might be to try and uh
detect a face in an image and if you
wanted to make an algorithm that did
that just with raw input pixels that'd
be quite hard um I certainly can't think
of just one off the top of my head but
if you had uh annotations of the image
so you said that okay there's a nose in
the image there's two eyes and there's a
mouth uh then I could even just write a
simple expression like if nose and two
eyes and mouth then face so that's the
idea behind image
features uh behind visual features in
reality annotating images like that is
really expensive uh
so what the standard image
classification approach might be take
some
input you extract features
algorithmically in some way whether it's
using um like some sort of gradients
optical flow
Etc and
then plugging those the results in into
a simple classifier like um a linear
classifier like we were talking about
earlier so that that's better than hand
annotating images it's algorithmic but
these features they're still
handcrafted uh in the sense that they're
not learned and they're very painful to
design and you have to be an expert and
the features that you might apply aren't
necessarily uh applicable to the domain
or the task that you want to
solve okay so maybe we can change the
image classification
approach the question is can we actually
learn these features from the data
instead of using these handd design ones
and the answer is of course yes um you
can use a neural network to learn
features so it turns out that using a
neural network like the one we were just
describing the Alex net
uh you can feed it raw images and along
the way within the inside the network it
learns a hierarchy of features so at
first it learns
edges and sort of Corners then if the
task is to identify faces it might learn
parts of faces um nose mouth eyes and
then it assembles those parts into like
higher level
ideas and this is really
powerful we've gotten really good
results uh we've seen really good
results for instance
on things like traffic sign recognition
and uh so that's just driving around
taking pictures of of traffic signs
recognizing what they are um the Google
house number competition where you drive
around and take photos of um just house
numbers
but really what was most astounding was
uh about I guess three years ago now uh
there was a group from
Google uh with Alex krvi they made this
network which I introduced to you
earlier that had 60 million parameters
and they um applied it to the imag net
competition and the imet competition is
basically an object uh classification
competition
where given basically images scraped off
of the
internet um of a thousand different
categories you try to recognize what
they are so they're natural images
they're not curated there is a whole
mass of them the training set for the
challenge was 1.2 million
images and it turns out with that amount
of data and on that kind of
problem their Network just totally
annihilated everybody else in the
competition so you can see on the left
uh that's the error rates for the Alex
net and everything else is at least 10%
higher so it's like 15% error rate
versus 25% error rate for all other
previous state of the art so that's a
pretty big deal it's really
cool um of
course uh even in computer vision you
might have different applications of
deep learning um one might be scene
parsing so taking an image and sort of
segregating it into what the different
parts
are and so that's these results are only
qualitative but it's really
impressive
um the question is then if deep learning
is so good and so awesome um are there
any
challenges so far we have seen that um
deep learning enables learning of
features rather than like hand
construction we've seen that there's
really impressive gains on tasks and
computer vision and other tasks and it
seems like there's potential for a lot
more impact so what are the cons well
let's uh dive a little bit into how the
workflow looks like for constructing a
deep learning
model first you have to get lots of
label data it's really important to have
lots of labeled data otherwise the
network um doesn't know what to do
okay then you train uh you split the the
data set into a training set and a
validation
set then you learn a deep neural
net then you try to validate
it and it probably didn't work so you go
back you add data you adjust hyper
parameters you change the model
architecture um and it's just a very
time consuming
process uh uh so you have to be an
expert in the field you have to have
lots of time you have to have lots of
computational resources for this to work
really so can we do
better well let's go back to this
learned hierarchy that um we discussed
earlier and let's assume that instead of
looking for
uh classification of faces we're trying
to
classify um of human faces let's say
we're trying to classify alien faces and
uh Alien faces it turns out also have
noses and eyes and mouths it's just that
the mouth might be on the top of the
head and the eyes on the
bottom we already have detectors for
eyes and mouths so shouldn't we be able
to reuse the information here
and
so the answer is
yes and that is uh what deep features
are it's the the idea of taking deep
learning and applying transferred
learning to deep
learning so let's go ahead and Define
transfer learning transfer learning is
the idea of using data from one domain
or training on uh human faces to learn
help learn on another okay so training
on alien faces and the workflow looks a
little something like this you have lots
of data you train a neurl net which has
really good accuracy because somebody
has spent the time to tune it we have do
have the appropriate amount of data
Etc and
so
now that neural net learned really rich
descriptions of the data and so we use
it as a feature
extractor now we can using this uh these
extracted features on some new task
where you only have a little bit of data
you can apply just a simple classifier
and get great ACC accuracy on a new
problem so uh let's dive a little bit
deeper into
that so what's learned in a neural net
okay
well the very last layer is just a
linear classifier as we saw
earlier and so that's very specific to
the original task but in order to be a
good classifier internally the network
had to learn very a very rich
representation of an image and that rich
representation can be used for a variety
of tasks so what you
do is you
propagate an image forward through the
network
and you chop off either the last layer
or maybe the last two layers and you end
up with a vector representation of uh an
image then on the new task you can plug
in that Vector representation into a
simple classifier and get good
results okay so this was explored using
this alexnet architecture that I was
describing it turns out that this
network turned on a million trained on a
million images of about a thousand CL
classes uh makes a surprisingly General
feature
extractor and this was first explored by
Jeff Dan who at all in a paper called
decaf okay so let's dig into the
workflow a little bit so transfer
learning with deep features you only
have a little bit of label
data you extract the
features you split into a training and
validation
set you learn a simple model you
validate it and it just
works in real life this is an example of
an instance where uh deep features did
really work the task was to discriminate
whether or not a trash can handle was
full or not that was certainly not in
the training set of imag net and yet
using deep features and the classifier
you could get quite good
results okay so what else can we do with
deep features we have these nice Vector
representations of
images okay well you could find similar
images does this look
familiar and how do you do that
well basically if two if we have a good
semantically meaningful uh
representation of each
image if two images are visually and
conceptually similar for us they should
also be close in this embedding space
and so you could simply do like a
nearest neighbor search to find similar
images and that's what we'll end up
doing okay so the last step of all this
is you have a nice model maybe it serves
up uh similar images and it's quite
practical so you want to send it off to
the world and so you want to deploy
it how do you do that well first you
train this
model okay and then you might want to
put it up to the
cloud where it can serve real-time
predictions and you can access it maybe
uh using a rest API so that's what we'll
be doing in our tutorial as
well so in
summary deep learning is a really
exciting machine learning development
but it's hard to use it's slow there's
lots of tuning needed um by applying
transfer learning to learning you get
deep features so you can reuse deep
models for new domains and it turns out
you need less data faster training times
and much simpler tuning while preserving
excellent
performance okay so next we we're going
to go ahead and build a deep learning
model and create an image similarity
service but before we move on I just
wanted to get a final count of how
people are doing on the installation
front so has every body gotten data and
installed
yes okay let's uh let's move right along
then if you need help at any point just
raise your hand and somebody will come
to you
great all right so now we're going to
trans transition over to
uh the I python notebooks okay so I'm
going to let's make this bigger can you
guys see that
whoops
um all right so I'm going to open up I
have on my
desktop uh the Pata Seattle
directory I'm going to open it
up and in there you should
see uh these three directories now I'm
going to activate my cond environment
for do de so Source activate do
n
okay and I'm going to spin up IPython
notebook
sure
um and so yeah that's just when once you
open up I python or IPython notebook
this is to make sure that everything is
healthy within graph lab
create
okay can you guys see
that all right um I'm going to go ahead
and move on if you need these instruct
or this these instructions this code
snippet it's also in this link which
should be accessible from the app ract
on the pi Data
Page
okay ENT
presentation let's make this
big all right
um open
up I'm going to to open up the Deep
learning Basics I python
notebook okay is that a good size for
everybody it looks like it's pretty big
great so in this first portion of the
tutorial we're going to get uh our hands
dirty with the graphlab create software
creating uh deep learning
model trained on character on on
basically digit recognition so the task
is to recognize digits they're from 0 to
9 and uh it's part of the Mist data set
which some of you may be familiar with
and just to sort of motivate this
problem this sort of application was one
of the first successful applications of
deep neural Nets in computer vision so
back in the 9s uh this kind of thing was
used when within ATMs to read uh checks
that were put in ATMs so pretty
important and quite successful
there so uh just one really quick
IPython notebook tutorial uh your guys's
is filled out and if you want to run a
line you can simply click on a code box
hit shift enter and it should execute
excellent okay so training a a deep uh
learning model basically consists of
four phases phase one is loading in the
data then you train the model then you
evaluate the model and maybe go on to
improve
it so let's start and load in the data
let's call the training data the train
and do graphlab dosf frame
emist train which is in that directory
archive okay an S frame is basically a
scalable data frame it scales out of
core and so it is a big enabler for a
lot of our
toolkits let's take a look at this
training
data it looks like it has two
columns uh one is label one is image
if we want to take a look at the image
we can do something like this train.
show and that opens up our visualization
tool or a graph lab
canvas if we transition to the table you
can see that the label column
corresponds with the image and you can
also see that many of these handwritten
digits uh are not so well written maybe
some people's handwriting is not as good
as others so it makes it a pretty
realistic data
set all right let's transition back to
the
notebook
whoops
okay also uh important is the validation
set so let's load that
in. SF frame and it's called mist. test.
graph lab uhoh I think I didn't make it
a
string
that's better okay and the validation
set is important because anytime you
want to evaluate a model you want to
make sure it's on data the model has
never seen before uh because that's
where most likely your what the task
your model will most likely be
performing is uh looking at data it's
never seen before so you want to make
sure it does well there so let's take a
look there there's an additional ID
column um that's in order to for some
something later down the line
but it also contains the label column
and the image column so it's consistent
with uh the training
set okay
so we've loaded in the data now is time
to train the model it's uh not too
difficult let's assign it
to neural
net
model equals
graphlab nural net classifier doc
create okay and then so we have to pass
in the training
set we also need to pass in the Target
or what we want the model to learn so in
this case that's the label we want the
model to learn what each digit
is the next thing we should pass in is
the validation
set so the schema of the validation set
should match the input set so we only
select two
columns so it's going to
be
validation
whoops and also so in your guys'
notebooks the validation set is equal to
none and we do perform evaluation later
but that's okay we also uh want might
want to
see how the model validates as its
training so let's select
image
and
label and then I guess one last thing
that I'm going to set is Max
iterations so an iteration is the number
of
passes through the data the algorithm
does the more passes uh the more
accurate the algorithm is in general but
um the more time it takes so it's a
trade-off
okay let's uh let's run this and see how
it
does so what's happening right now is
it's generating an architecture and then
actually performing the
training so you can see that the the
generated architecture here is has seven
layers um you might ask how it was
generated well it was just uh based on
the data it selects the same default so
if the data is image data it selects a
convolution neural net if it's uh just
vectors it might choose uh neural net
without
convolutional uh layers and let's
explore the dra the training statistics
a little
bit
um maybe I'll zoom out because the
formatting is a little off can you still
see okay so we can see we had three
iterations about 5,300 examples in each
iteration
each uh iteration took a few
seconds and the training accuracy jumped
significantly um and the validation
accuracy is actually quite good it's
better than training accuracy which is
interesting so in the end we end up with
an 81% training accuracy and an
89.9% validation
accuracy and uh we
get a few thousand examples per second
as throughput if you were to run this
with one of the with a GPU using our GPU
egg you'd see really significant speed
ups but anyways I wanted to give you
guys maybe a minute to play around uh
specifically with the max number of
iterations if you haven't caught up to
here you can click on the cell click
cell and hit run all above so why don't
we take just a minute and if you have
any issues once again uh why you grab
our Tas raise your hand all
right I in the meantime I can take
questions
yeah so this is trying to use a single
thread yeah so there are advantages to
using multiple threads uh primarily that
it's faster uh but so that is something
on our road map right now
yeah another
question
okay you would like me to scroll
up
anything sorry could you repeat the
question
I see so basically the the validation
set has to have the same schema as the
the training set so if you see if we
take a look here you can see the
validation has ID label and image well
train has only label and image and so uh
basically you're just pulling out the
image and the label columns by passing
in
uh a
list yeah yeah another questions I
miss yeah so it's it's a fairly
straightforward her istic basically if
uh there is an image as the type uh
it'll choose the convolutional network
that we see here um otherwise if it's a
vector type which our s frame supports
then it chooses an a different
architecture without the convolutional
layers it's just some fully connected
layers um I'm going to have to move on
but uh I'll take more questions towards
the
end um did anybody find anything
interesting when playing around with the
max iterations at
all uh so what I was hoping you guys
would see at least was
um that as the number of iterations
progress so in this case Epoch and
iterations are
interchangeable the error goes down
really rapidly at first but not as
rapidly after and so the takeaway
message here is if you're just playing
around with a neural net trying to get
the right architecture this or that or
the other making your data correct um
use only a few iterations at first and
then once you're actually using this um
Network out in the wild train it for as
many iterations as you
need
okay
so that's nice uh we have train a model
it seems to do fairly well on the eval
the validation Set uh let's take a
deeper look at how well this model is
actually
doing okay so we have this neural net
model and let's call invoke valuate and
put in the validation set as a parameter
oh maybe it's just validation okay it's
just
validation okay and we see that we get
about 90% accuracy which was what you
saw before but the other thing that
comes up when you evaluate is the
confusion Matrix and the confusion
Matrix basically tells you what
categories are getting confused with
what
categories um it is a matrix so this is
in s sort of a a table form but let's
investigate it the uh the model and this
confusion Matrix using graphlab canvas
it'll be a little bit more
parsable so neural net
model.
show okay and that should we should be
able to open up the graphlab canvas page
and it should
refresh you can tab over to evaluation
and you can take a look at the conf
Fusion Matrix so on the left we have the
real true labels and on up high we have
the labels that are uh predicted by the
model so for example in 963 instances
the model predicted a zero and was
actually a
zero
but uh in two instances the model
predicted a zero but it was actually a
three so ideally you would see high
values across the diagonal and Zer
everywhere else and this might give you
a little bit Insight insight
into what the model is really learning
and if the confu the in the
um mistakes it's making are ones that
you care about so let's dive a little
deeper and look for the high numbers off
the
diagonal and we can see that in 101
cases uh the model thought it was a
seven but it really was a nine and that
might make sense uh because a nine
without that little circle at the top
being written very clearly is might
actually look quite similar to a seven
even to a human
so makes sense um we can still
investigate a little bit
further I'm going to go ahead and go
back to the
notebook so here I have a helper
function that finds the
misclassifications in the data um so it
basically runs predicts the entire
validation set and then finds where the
true label does not match
the um the the predicted label so let's
define
that and
then find
misclassifications with this model and
with this validation
data so
validation neural net
model okay so while that let's take a
look at what misclassifications actually
are okay so you can see in the left hand
column you have the label so that's the
True
Value
and the class column you
have what the model thought the image
was and then in the right hand most
column you have the score and the score
is basically just a confidence
prediction by the
model of
what of of how confident the model is in
this prediction so if it's
zero then the model is extremely
inconfidentes making or unconfident
sorry and if it's one it's extremely
confident it's a range from 0 to one
it's a probability
score okay so what we're really
interested in
is those cases where the model is really
confident but maybe actually isn't
correct so let's sort
by the
score okay so I'm going to do
misclassification do
sort sorting by score and I'm going to
do
ascending equals false and all that does
is it sorts in reverse
order okay
so sorted
misclassifications we can see that now
it is indeed sorted with the highest
confidences towards the top is everybody
with me
yeah Okay
cool
so this is still not that insightful um
we may want to actually look at the
images that are getting mclassified so
let's go back to Canvas again and
explore
okay so we can see that for instance in
this top row um model thought it was a
two it was was actually a seven but when
you look at the image itself I honestly
might have made that same mistake
so I don't know I I feel like that's
okay but there are some cases where the
model is very clearly wrong uh for
instance in row four here it
thinks uh it's a three but it's very
clearly a five so maybe the model has a
little bit of room for
improvement so that's going to be our
our next topic here um is how to go
about improving a neural net
model
let's go do
that okay so this is a
graphic that I was introduced to um a
few months back I it was presented uh by
Andre ying and it's a very it's a basic
recipe for machine learning with respect
effect to deep learning in particular
and so you let's go through this little
flowchart first let's ask the question
does it do well on the training
data if no then you need a bigger
Network and the reason for that
is
maybe um the network you made is not
expressive enough to come to to capture
the mapping from the input to the output
and so like we discussed a neural net
can model any function so long as it has
enough hidden units so you might just
want to add more hidden units okay all
right but let's say it does do well on
the training data if it does well on
some test data as well then you're done
for now at least and uh if it's if you
does not do well on the test
data then you might need to add more
data and the reason is if you you have a
very expressive model it might capture
sort of random noise in the training Set
uh for instance in the case of sevens
some people write sevens with a strike
through them some people write sevens
without a strike through them
and the if the training set contains
only sevens with a strike through them a
very expressive model might think that
only things with a strike through them
are sevens and so when it gets hit with
a seven without the strike it's
confused and so the solution there is
either add sevens without a strike to
the training set or make the model a
little bit
smaller uh so that it doesn't capture
that that little piece of
information and so that
effect of capturing random noise in the
training set is called overfitting
here's a nice
little
graphic that that deals with
that
um so basically at a certain point even
though your training error keeps going
down your test error starts diverging
and so that's a a really important
indicator of overfitting so there's one
more solution to overfitting that I
didn't mention earlier it's a little bit
hacky but it works um is if you're
monitoring the difference between the
training error and the test error and
they start diverging at any point you
can just stop the training right there
and if you're happy with the performance
at that point
so that's that
um maybe we have a little bit of time so
we can explore a little bit how
to uh increase the network size in our
case and sort of play with network size
so let's do that
I'm going to
assign new network to I'm going to pull
out the Theology of the neural net model
we
created okay so it's that neural net
model and then in square
brackets it's
Network okay so new
network you can see this uh topology
that we we were looking at earlier and
we want to identify a spot where you can
increase the number of
layers um so we discussed convolutional
layers Max pooling layers and fully
connected
layers uh convolutional layers you can
increase the number of parameters there
uh by increasing the number of
convolutional filters or channels so in
each convolutional layer remember we had
a little filter roaming around but in
each layer you might have multiple so we
could play with the number of
channels um we can also play with just
the number of hidden units in a fully
connected layer like in layer three here
so if we increase that the network
becomes more
expressive um one key thing is this last
fully connected layer uh connects the
output and the final number of units
must match the number
of the uh sorry the number of classes in
the task so in this case 10 so that's a
little bit off limits for us right
now okay so let's let's play with layer
three just as a really it's an arbitrary
Choice um
now now so let's do this
new network okay then we can pull out
there's a layers attribute which is just
the list of the
layers we have an index we were talking
about the third layer okay so then we
can do graph
flab do deep
learning. layers so it's a layers module
and there's a full connection layer
object
Constructor and you pass into that
Constructor the number of hidden units
that you want we previously
had uh 100 so let's up that to
500 okay and so let's take a look at our
new
network
oops okay so you can see in layer three
we now have 500 units whereas
previously we had 100
units so I'm I'm going to type out uh
the command for How to Train this guy so
let's do
improved Network equals graphlab do
neuronet classifier doc
create and then it's going to be
train and then Target once again equals
label this is just Verbatim what we had
earlier um validation set
equals
validation okay and once again it was
believe it was
image and
label
whoops okay and the last thing we have
Max
iterations equal to three and the last
thing is we want to set the
network um parameter to equal that new
network that we set okay so let's train
it and I'll give you guys uh a few
minutes to experiment with this maybe a
minute or two maybe you want to dig into
evaluating the model and if you have any
questions or problems once again um
raise your hand ta will come by if you
have a question for me I can answer that
as well so let's take like
a in fact let's take a a maybe a 5
minute break if you guys want to go to
the restroom or something too
so
okay go for
it is there constant time or or addition
from adding like 400 more layers here or
400 more units to this layer or is
it it's probably going to be more than
that right because uh it's really the
number of connections that you care
about and so that's quadratic I believe
right cuz it's a it's like a it's like
an inner
product
yeah
okay can you check people are still
having installation issues to raise
their hand okay yeah guys if you're
still having installation issues raise
your hand we'll have people come
by
where would you like me to scroll back
up
to this right
here
no we'll start back up in 2 minutes
[Music]
minutes what's
up make
sure okay
okay
yes
uhhuh from the the documentation looks
like random initialize I get
same yeah so it is I mean it's random
weights but I'm
guessing it's it's okay there's two
possibilities here I don't actually know
the answer either it's random weights
but there's a seed to it um which I
don't think is the case or there's it
actually is learning uh the same thing
each time which on a small problem like
this is seems like it's not unlikely oh
I
see
yeah slides you know I'm not sure if I
I'll i' have to ask some folks if I
confidential company data maybe I don't
know we'll see all
right all right folks let's get let's
get started
um
so we just got a little glimpse of what
it's like to train an earlet uh this was
a fairly small problem uh but as your
problems get bigger and bigger the the
procedure takes longer and longer and
it's becomes much more challenging so
we're going to dive into using uh an
already trained model on imag net um to
use that
model as a feature extractor and to
actually go ahead and build that similar
uh dress
retriever uh so
let's navigate way from this particular
notebook and then you can go up a
directory level and there's a another
directory called image similarity
search okay and let's open up that
notebook has everybody been able to find
the notebook
there yes yes okay if no please feel
free to interrupt and let me know all
right so
in in this notebook we're going to go
ahead and build that
dress retriever uh sorry image
similarity model and so that basically
takes four steps first we're going to
load in the data again then we're going
to extract the features like we were
discussing um with the Alex net model
then finally we're going to calculate
distances
between the different uh examples in the
training set and then find the Sim most
similar items so you can retrieve
them okay so let's call this
data image
SF and it's
located in
the is my I may not have imported graph
lab
that's an important First Step all right
and that's going to be in the data
directory so if it's one directory level
up so it's data
slash
um SF uncor process. SF frame
okay so has everybody been able to load
in that s frame great
um let's explore it let's take a look at
it okay so we can see that it has a
number of columns one is ID which is
just an identifier then we have a name
column uh a brand column a price and an
image column
so uh all of these columns are actually
quite
informative but we're going to focus on
the image
one uh so let's take a look at
that okay so it
just
hell okay uh well you could see that it
had images of
dresses uh and so that's what we're
recommending and uh serving up so that
makes
sense okay
so we've loaded in the data now uh we're
going to extract
features and so the thing we need for
that is we need that pre-trained model
and so remember that this is the alexnet
model
um which is the one in this graphic
here and the one I described in the
presentation graph lab. load
model it's going to be
uh
string relative
path data and it's going to be called
the imag net model
okay let's take a look at what's in
there it's a fairly large model so it
might take a minute to load what's
that I see okay thank you for the
tip I guess it got uh confused with that
image
column let's go back to the image
similarity notebook okay
maybe I'm going to kill it and then
restart
it well then uh so once this loads we'll
be able to continue with the procedure
of extracting the features using the
model
um all right I'm going to go ahead and
restart the kernel and try
again
restart one we loading in the S frame
again and let's load the pre-train
model there we
go perfect so we have this pre-trained
model
uh we can see that it was trained on
uh 1.2 million
examples it got a training accuracy of
uh 62% which seems bad but for such a
hard task it's quite good it was
state-of-the-art several years ago and
it
took many thousands of seconds to train
so it was a few days so it's a good
thing we're not uh having to retrain it
right now somebody has done it for
us um and the next thing that I wanted
to to look at is
just the model
architecture okay
so you can pull out the network
topology okay and you can see that it's
has convolutional layers followed by
pulling layers followed by convolutional
layers so on and so
forth and you can see that it's quite
large it's much bigger than the network
than that we trained in the previous uh
section of the
session and then there's some other
training parameters such as learning
rate here
okay
so we have this network we have the data
let's try extracting a
feature so I'm going to do example
feature equals pre-trained
model
do extract
features okay and so the important thing
thing here is that you only
do uh one image or else it might lock up
your I python notebook session it's a
very big model it takes a lot of effort
to pump uh several thousand images
through and if we had a GPU it would
take um maybe a few minutes maybe a
minute or two but with a CPU can take
quite a while maybe upwards of a half
hour so if you're going to be doing this
for a lot of images uh be sure to either
have some time or do it on a GPU uh we
support multiple gpus now or maybe
distribute it with some map
job okay so let's see what this example
feature looks
like
and it's uh not very interpretable but
it is uh a vector representation like we
were
discussing um and this is what the
computer uses to to represent the
image uh just to just for fun let's take
a look at the length of the example
feature
whoops uh example feature
zero and you can see that it's 496
dimensional and if we go back to the
network uh we're extracting
from the second to last layer where the
number of hidden units is 496 so the the
dimensionality of the vector makes
sense okay so in this next code block
where it's commented out that's how you
would extract the features uh of the
entire s frame but we've done that
already for you because of the the time
constraints so let's
take a look at the image SF once
more and you can
see that there's a features column okay
so is everyone with me here has
everybody been able to extract a feature
from a single
example okay um if feel once again feel
free if you have the need to interrupt
me at any time all right
so we have these extracted features
now we want to be able to both calculate
the distances uh between these Vector
representations of all the images in our
s frame and uh retrieve similar items
for particular
queries so let's do
that uh so we want to create a nearest
neighbors
model so it's gra once again it's the
same API it's uh nearest graphlab
nearest
neighbors do
create okay and
then we
have uh our
image SF is what we're creating the
nearest neighbors model on and we're
only
using
the uh the features column all uh so so
that
is what we pass into to this features
parameter right here and so let's go
ahead and create the
model excellent so now we can sort of
look at the model I can see that it's a
nearest neighbors model with uh the the
training set has 7,000 examples and
there were 4,096 features or the
dimensionality of the features okay any
questions everybody
following
good so
now let's uh let's put this into
action let's pull out a an image this
one in particular is one that we've
selected beforehand because it's nice
and blue so let's take a
look okay so we have a blue
dress and
we want
to
retrieve similar dresses for that blue
dress so we can do something like uh
nearest neighbors model.
query and then uh we can do blue and
then
let's uh how many nearest neighbors do
we want this going to be a number five
five near neighbors great excellent
so retrieved calculated all the pairs
pair wise distances now let's take a
look at the
output and um we have IDs and
distances so I have a little helper
function here which given this sort of
uh
output goes ahead and takes these IDs
which correspond to the row ID of the
original s frame and join that
back and then since with that join um we
lose the the order we sort it based on
distance again so let's go ahead and do
that whoops and let's
say return equals retrieve
images
labels
okay
and see what
happens and then
return okay so we
have uh a few items
here and let's view it in canvas
again okay so as we can
see um we have five really similar blue
addresses so these deep features really
do capture uh visual similarity very
well okay I would like to invite all of
you guys
to go ahead and just spend a few minutes
playing with uh
different examples and seeing sort of
proving to yourselves and seeing how it
works for you so and if you have any
questions I'll take questions now and
also uh once again the Tas are here to
help in the meantime I'll start playing
with it too let's see if I can come up
with anything
interesting sure
sorry where would you like me to go just
here is fine
okay yeah
oh yeah so
that's yeah so that's uh that's
definitely I mean so when we're
measuring similarity of the image we're
not just focusing on the dress um
so that this doesn't deal with that
right now um
but one way to deal with that might be
to do some sort of background extraction
procedure and then just pull out the
dress and then do some sort of
um some sort of sim a similar thing to
this and so there are some methods for
background extraction and I believe open
CV has some implemented that are quite
good yeah any other questions yeah sorry
just a curiosity how is that this
classify like the gold and white
versus uh so you'll see we we'll see how
that goes sorry the question is how does
this classify the uh the blue or gold
dress question right uh from a while ago
and we'll see that in an upcoming
segment so you'll
see someone a question about how
it person as well not
justess right so um it sort of measures
distances of the whole image sorry the
question is uh whether or not the this
similarity metric incorporates not just
the dress but also the model wearing it
and the answer is yes it takes the whole
image so similarities between models
will uh indeed contribute to the
similarities between images uh there are
ways of dealing with this for instance
you could ex uh use some sort of
background extraction mechanism to just
pull out the dress and then do a similar
procedure to this or alternatively um
you
could yeah exactly so that's that's
that's true in this case but in other
cases it might not be
yeah okay uh has everybody gotten a
chance to play around with this a little
bit okay well I wanted to look at uh one
more example just to sort of show that
sometimes
the
uh sometimes if you get really unique
dresses or if the uh there's not a whole
lot of data to populate the similarity
graph you might get interesting results
so I'm going to go ahead and pull out
this example
here okay so let's go back to
Canvas and it's uploading and you can
sort of see that we have a waffle dress
um yeah it's it's sort of interesting
now it's it's made uh even worse by the
fact that the image is a little
distorted right now but let's see if
there are any similar
dresses Okay this is the wrong
one all right
so the the command we had
previously was
is all right
labels equals nearest neighbor
model do
query and then it's going to
be uh interesting and then let's let's
retrieve maybe 20 nearest neighbors this
time just for
fun whoops that's a
minus
okay and
uh the name of the function that I just
defined was retrieve
images
so an equals retrieve images of
labels okay and let's take let's
investigate what kind of similar
dresses we
get okay so it's it's not completely
crazy um we still pick up I guess you
can see a lot of the color but uh
the dresses are not as similar and that
is most likely
because there is just a fairly unique
dress but it is potentially also the
case that maybe these deep features
don't fully uh capture what this dress
is about and so maybe there are other uh
dresses that are similar to this so that
would warrant
investigating
um
in yeah so that's that's another thing
uh people frequently use cosine
distances because it turns out that uh
the direct direction of the vector
matters more than the magnitude of the
vector uh if you can imagine like maybe
one element or one feature of the
feature Vector is like the bless of a
dress
um it might not matter whether something
is really really really blue or just
mostly blue and those differences in
magnitude can be quite large so you're
right uh a cosine distance is something
that might work well here and it is
something we support so we can even try
it out um if you guys
want do you guys want to try out cosine
distance yeah all right let's let's
let's see if there's any difference um
so you have to do nearest neighbor model
cosine uh equals graph lab.
nearest
neighbors do
create image SF
okay so this is identical to what we
were doing before features
equals
features and
distance equals
cosine
okay okay so we uh just constructed that
let's just make sure that it is actually
a cosine distance there
um interesting it doesn't say uh but
let's see
uh coine and
distance or maybe list
Fields I'm kind of winging this right
now okay so we
can get the
distance
yeah so it's a coine distance all right
so we can go back to this nearest Ena
model cosine
query and then we can
uh get those answers and show
it so
I don't know do you guys think
this is significantly
different it's a little bit different I
mean we picked up a purple dress here
but it's it's fairly similar it's there
still I guess uh one key thing that I've
noticed is that especially when it comes
to clothing the um one of the key
features this model picks up on is
colors
so if uh there's anything with a very
like distinguishing color then it it
will pick up on that especially solid
colors okay so with that um we do have
just a handful of
exercises uh if you want to try to give
them a try I'm going to give you guys
just a few minutes to get started um if
you if you want we can help answer
questions about them and uh after that
so after let's say 3 or 4 minutes um
we'll go back to actually going ahead
and deploying this model so you can play
with it yourself via arrest API so let's
let's take a three or four minute break
and I'll uh I'll take questions now as
well no
questions
so just to go through what these
exercises are the first exercise is to
find the least similar to that blue
dress that we
found uh the second is to find like the
most average dress and the third is to
find the most unique dress all of these
are potentially
interesting uh
results I hope you guys got a chance to
attempt at least some of these exercises
but we're going to move on to the next
stage um just to recap in this section
we learned how to build a similar image
service um which recommends or gives
similar images to a query it's using
transfer learning and so we've actually
saw some really good results with the
blue dress and I hope you guys saw some
other really nice results uh when you
got a chance to play around with
it um and before that we
also learned how to uh just build a deep
learning model you can see
that uh it's really nice when somebody
does it for you and uh it actually
didn't take a whole lot of effort to
come up with something that was quite
meaningful and quite
practical so in the next stage of of
this tutorial we're going to be talking
about how to take the model you just
built and uh put it up into the cloud so
you can query it from a uh from any app
from from any Source okay so I'm going
to go up and go into this predictive
service
directory and then I'm going to open up
the Predictive Services I python
notebook okay so we're going to be using
data predict Ive services to uh perform
this task so data Predictive Services is
basically just a tool that allows you to
package up any code you might have
whether it's pyit learn arbitrary python
code maybe graphlab code and put it
into um a cluster which is both scalable
and robust and can be queried via a
restful API uh it can be on premise or
or in the cloud or in
ec2
and Performing such a such a thing
basically consists of three steps the
first step is creating a predictive
object or a a function that you push up
to the predictive service then you stand
up the predictive service and then
finally you query
it
so in order to to create a predict our
predictive object here the goal is given
some URL return URLs of similar images
so what we need to do for that is we
need to have a pre-trained
model this is the neural net Alex net
model that we were using just in the
previous
section and we also need the nearest
Neighbors model that we were using in
the previous section so I'm loading both
of those
in
okay in the
next uh little segment I have a snippet
of
code it's uh basically a function which
takes a
URL okay and then it
constructs a graphlab image out of that
URL resizes it uh now this is important
because neural Nets only take fixed
input so and images tend to come in a
variety of sizes so the standard thing
to do is to either crop or to warp them
to that input size and a fairly standard
one is 256 to by 256 by 3 okay so then
we take that graph lab image and uh we
put it in an S
frame we then go ahead and and extract
features from that image and then
query the nearest neighbors model this
is identical to what we were doing just
in the previous
section uh one little addition
is we go ahead and we use the ID of the
returning answers and concatenate a URL
to it and that's because is we're
actually hosting all of these images um
on S3 and we'll be able to reconstruct
the images from the URLs instead of
sending images over the wire um or down
from the predictive service which can be
quite
expensive okay so does everybody follow
me with how that function Works any
questions no okay let's move on so uh I
pulled just a query URL from the
internet maybe some of you will
recognize
it uh so let's take a
look so the the question we're going to
try to answer
is whether this is uh blue or gold I
think this looks quite blue on this
screen but you know I don't know what is
the Deep learning model
thing okay
so let let's
try to answer that question using this
uh predictive object that we created
addess
similar query
URL okay and so what's happening is it's
downloading the image and then
extracting the features and then going
through that process okay
so we have a list of URLs image urls
so now what we can
do
is we
can apply a Lambda function to this s
frame and we do this by calling out
pulling out this image
URL calling a DOT apply on it
Lambda
X and graph lab do image of X and so
what's happening here is for each item
in this uh in this
Sr we're creating a new column where the
value in that column is just an image
that is reconstructed from each of
these URLs so let's go ahead and do
that depending on the speed of the
internet here this might take just a
moment because we're downloading images
um hey didn't seem too
bad and let's take a look at
what our model
thinks of blue and
gold okay it sees Stripes primarily
neither blue nor gold so even the model
is confused um but you can see you can
sort of get a sense for what kind of
things uh these models these deep
learning models pick up like I said
solid colors are often picked up and
also patterns like stripes and those are
very distinctive
things for the model okay so we have we
have this function that will serve as
our custom predictive object and the
next stage of being able to query uh a
predictive service is actually creating
the predictive service so here I have uh
set of commented lines and what they do
is they stand up an ec2 cluster and
create a predictive service on them so
I'm not going to run through this
exactly in the interest of time but I
will I will not run this in the interest
of time but I will walk through it so
the first thing you would do is you
would set the
credentials um so if you have AWS
credentials you set them here then uh
you would create an ec2
environment
and within this Constructor this ec2
config Constructor you can pass in
things like the type of instance you
want to use or the number of instances
or um and things like that and
then we create a
deployment with uh graphlab deoy
predictive service. create and we pass
in
a name and this configuration and also
the um we also pass in a a path for
where the state will be
stored okay and so now we've created
this predictive service and you might go
ahead and add the custom predictive
object and then apply those changes so
what I'm going to do is I'm instead of
standing up a predictive service like
this I'm going to go ahead and load one
that already exists so let's let's try
that and let's take a look at
it okay so this particular one has uh a
name of predictive uh predictive service
tutorial dl2 it has this state path uh
one important bit is the API key so if
you want to access this uh predictive
service this deployment from the outside
world via restful API you will need to
provide this API key um you can provide
the API key within the construction of
the predictive service or it can
generate one for you and then the last
thing is uh the load balancer DNS name
this will become part of the Endo for
the the restful query so that's
important as well all right and here we
we can see that I was playing with the
predictive service beforehand it already
has some objects but uh let's go ahead
and put another one
in
so let's do that and then
deployment.
add it's going to be
dress
similar that's the name of the
predictive object and then I'm also
going to just pass in the name of the
function that we defined
earlier okay so we have
uh we added it now we need to apply
changes
okay and so this is taking just a moment
because it needs to package up uh the
nearest neighbors model and the image
net model both of which are actually
fairly large especially the imag net
model um just but just point this out
out this is kind of
cool it looks at your function that
you're sending up and introspects it and
sees
what what um objects it needs to package
up and pickle uh so in this case this
pre-trained model is not defined within
the function it is uh defined outside
the scope of the function but this uh
uploading of the predictive objects
knows to go and grab the pre-trained
model and the nearest neighbors model so
that's kind of neat and another
interesting thing is that with these
Predictive Services you can use
arbitrary python packages you just need
to decorate the function with something
like at
required
packages and provide a list but that's
not necessary here at
all
okay
so we
have successfully up uploaded these
changes let's take a look at the
status of the deployment and get an idea
for what's going
on okay it looks like we've have a bunch
of we've loaded successfully the uh the
dress similar object it's version one
and we have a a cache enabled so if you
have successive queries that are
identical it'll return them they'll
it'll back the answer very
quickly Okay so we've stood up this
predictive service in just a few lines
of code um now it's time to query it we
can query it using the graph lab API so
the way you would do that is
deployment.
query
and address
similar and then you would pass in the
parameters so
query URL is this making sense to
everybody does anybody have any
questions no okay see if this
works all right and you get back in a
Json format a uh a list of images that
makes sense
uh
so that's neat but we really want to be
able to access this from outside of
python maybe you're creating a
JavaScript application or a mobile
application and you want to be able to
create uh query this predictive object
and so we have some different um
bindings
for uh clients so we have JavaScript and
Java I think and python that are just
for that but also you can use any other
way um that you please for querying a
restful API so so here I have a function
which performs the restful
query um it takes a
URL and it queries this end point right
here where the first
substitution is the name of
the uh the load balancer DNS and the
second substitution here is the name of
the custom predictive object that we
sent up so
this is runnable code for you guys uh
the only thing that you'll have to
change is you folks have dress similar
and I have dress similar backup we had
to restart a predictive service and uh I
didn't want to and so I already had a
custom predictive object loaded but I
wasn't able to load one in this segment
of
code
here um so just change that to backup
okay
and with
that we have a function for restful
query now we have uh we can query it so
let's do that and take a look at the
response so we have a response once
again of a list of image URLs so this is
really cool um we've done it totally
without
graph lab create we can do this
anywhere and
then with this response we want to be
able to investigate it to just take a
look at the answers um we're going to
load it back into an S frame because
canvas is nice to look at things so this
helper function takes that response and
uh sticks it back in an S
frame okay so let's take a
look
so it might I don't know what's going on
what's okay there we go so we have
images it was downloading images cool
then let's take take a look and see if
the answer matches that you query URL I
gave was the blue and gold dress so
let's see if it matches what we had at
the beginning of this
section
okay yeah so it's the exact same answer
I I'd like to invite you guys to spend a
few minutes just querying this guy and
you can find any image off the internet
that's a JPEG or PNG um and it'll go
ahead and give you the most similar
results so why don't you guys spend some
time playing with that cool and I'll
take
[Music]
questions whoops
any questions where you successful
application of deep learning outside of
Imes so we've seen you can see
successful applications of deep learning
outside of uh
images um it's probably most mature in
computer vision
but I guess uh speech recognition is a
big one uh because there you also have
this structure where
the what you're saying is related to
what you were just saying previously and
afterwards um also some text processing
analysis tasks so there's been some work
for instance in word Toc uh which
takes uh word and turns it into a
feature Vector so that's also a form of
deep learning um and then also there
have been recurrent neural Nets which uh
are fair make fairly good link anguage
models so sort of these there are a few
canonical tasks there's a lot of
research to be done still it's a pretty
new field so yeah um any other questions
yeah are your introductory slides
available online somewhere so I I will
have to ask Folks at my company um but I
would like to make them available so if
possible I'll make them available yeah
any other
questions okay okay
so with no other questions I did want to
say that we
have this is
really we do have some other talks we're
giving some other talks um
so Jay okay hold
on uh Jay who is in the audience right
now raise your hand is giving a talk on
S frames and S graphs tomorrow those are
our scalable data structures
um and they're really cool and then we
have a sponsor talk on Sunday by our
director of product Sean skul and so
he'll describe a bit of what our mission
is with data so uh thank you very much
guys um if you have any questions I'll
be happy to take them thank
[Applause]
you